netflix even has joined the parade
against the woke we've got more info
from the daily wire a new corporate
culture memo from netflix is taking a
hard-line stance on attempts to silence
artistic
expression by warning those who are
offended by the streaming services
content that they may want to go find a
job somewhere else variety reports that
the change in netflix's company culture
appears to be in large part due to the
backlash the streaming service faced
from woke employees last year over its
dave chappelle special which the
employees claimed was transphobic the
updated netflix culture memo includes a
new section called artistic expression
that states it will not censor specific
artists or voices even if employees
consider the content harmful if you'd
find it hard to support our content
breath netflix may not be the best place
for you the memo states later adding
that employees may be required to work
on projects that they perceive to be
harmful and that if they have a hard
time accepting their work assignment
they might want to consider working
somewhere else well hot diggity dog
you're going to make people do the job
you hired them for that is completely
bananas huh i mean really it's happening
do you see it's happening these
companies which have capitulated to a
bunch of purple haired freaks are
finally saying enough is enough netflix
stock has taken taken a crazy crazy dive
uh 72 percent down over the last six
months so do you think that maybe over
there they're going boy guys you know
we've been doing all this woke
programming and sure it all sucks and
we've ruined comedy and there's nothing
funny and people just literally spend
most of their time on netflix trying to
find things to watch and they can't find
anything and we've got a bunch of these
children working for us that are
boycotting us while they're supposed to
be at work and blah blah blah
they've all become cult members um
pretty good pretty good they're finally
pushing against it now i don't have any
great faith in netflix because it is
still run by this guy reed hastings and
reid hastings put millions and millions
of dollars into the campaign to keep
gavin newsom as governor of california
and and to re
really horrible you may have seen them
last summer these ads against larry
elder basically calling larry elder a
white supremacist so that was what the
netflix ceo was doing uh but they're
also now axing woke programs on netflix
which is good now i'd like to see if
they can make some actual good programs
that would be nice so i have something
to watch besides seinfeld but they're
getting rid of the woke nonsense a
little more from dw
netflix has pulled the plug on dr ibram
x kenny's show anti-racist baby along
with several other proposed offerings
that would present a nod or a total body
immersion experience to woke culture
according to a report from variety
candy's anti-racist baby which was aimed
at preschoolers was one of the animated
shows to get the axe the others were the
ava duvernay produced wings of fire
series and a film titled with kind
regards from kindergarten so do you see
what's happening here the corporations
because the people
this is because of you this isn't just
elon musk this isn't just because a few
of us
that are public people are standing up
it's because people are starting to vote
with their dollars disney plus is being
cancelled at record levels netflix stock
diving at record levels because people
are canceling at record levels it's all
happening right in front of us this
thing that we all knew was wrong
that was gross that was infecting
everything this woke virus this woke
disease it's being defeated as we speak
now give it its credit give the devil
it's due it morphs it changes
always the badness the ideas of
collectivism and and all of these things
they don't just go away but good things
are starting to happen